STAND BY, SENATOR, WE'LL GET
BACK TO YOU.
WE DO HAVE OUR PANEL UP.
LET ME GO TO THEM.
OLIVIA TROYE IS THERE WITH US.
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE A PLAN
B.
STEPHANIE GRISHAM IS ALSO WITH
US, THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY OLIVIA TROYE.
SHE WAS AN ADVISER TO MIKE
PENCE.
OLIVIA, LET ME START WITH YOU
FIRST.
THESE MIDTERM ELECTIONS DID NOT
BRING THE RED WAVE MANY
EXPECTED.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
YOU KNOW, YOU WERE SO CLOSE TO
THE -- ACTUALLY BOTH YOU HAVE
WERE VERY CLOSE.
YOU WERE INVOLVED IN THE INNER
WORKS OF THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
I WONDER IF THIS WAS AS MUCH A
REFERENDUM ON THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AS IT WAS ON THE
PRESIDENT WHO IS IN WHITE HOUSE
RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH, LOOK, I THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE VOTED FOR
SANITY.
AND THEIR VOICES WERE HEARD.
AND I THINK THEY'RE TIRED OF THE
UGLY POLITICKING THAT'S GOING
ON, ESPECIALLY IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
I THINK DEMOCRACY DID MATTER.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
CORRECT IN CALLING IT OUT AND
CALLING OUT THE EXTREME MAGA AND
WHAT IT STANDS FOR.
AND I THINK -- AND I ALSO THINK
LOOK, WOMEN CAME OUT, YOUNG
PEOPLE CAME OUT AND THEY SAID
ENOUGH.
WE DON'T LIKE THE DIRECTION THAT
THIS IS GOING IN WITH ALL THESE
CRAZY CANDIDATES THAT THE GOP
DECIDED TO RUN.
IT'S NOT JUST A REFERENDUM ON
TRUMP.
IT'S A REFERENDUM ON THE GOP AS
A WHOLE, BECAUSE HE DIDN'T RUN
THESE CANDIDATES ALONE.
>> AND STEPHANIE, YOUR FORMER
BOSS HAS SAID HE IS GOING TO
MAKE THIS SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT
ON TUESDAY.
HIS OWN ADVISERS ARE ESSENTIALLY
SAYING NOW THAT HE IS GOING TO
HAVE THIS ANNOUNCEMENT, THAT HE
IS GOING TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN
2024.
YOU AND I, WE USED TO BE OUT
THERE ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
TOGETHER.
WE KNOW WHAT THIS IS GOING TO
ENTAIL IN THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS.
DO YOU THINK THE PARTY GOES WITH
HIM?
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME, AND I
WANT TO SAY, I WANT TO HAVE A
CAVEAT HERE, WE'VE ALL SEEN THIS
MOVIE BEFORE, RIGHT?
RIGHT AFTER JANUARY 6, WE HAD
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND McCARTHY
SAYING THIS IS ALL TRUMP'S
FAULT, ET CETERA, ET CETERA WE
NEED TO MOVE ON, ET CETERA.
ET CETERA.
A FEW DAYS LATER McCARTHY WAS
DOWN AT MAR-A-LAGO TO KISS THE
RING.
WITH THIS WE'VE SEEN BEFORE, I'M
GOING ECHO WHAT LOW LIVIA JUST
SAID.
THE VOTERS HAVE SPOKEN, AND THEY
HAVE SPOKEN.
AND I THINK THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
REALLY NEEDS TO LOOK WITHIN
RIGHT NOW AND DECIDE ARE WE
GOING TO GO WITH THE VOTERS WHO
HIRE US OR ARE WE GOING TO GO
WITH THIS ONE MAN, DONALD TRUMP.
AND SADLY, I THINK REPUBLICANS
ARE JUST GOING TO KEEP WITH THE
PEOPLE WHO KEEP THEM IN OFFICE,
THE PEOPLE WHO HIRE THEM ON.
>> AND OLIVIA, I WANT TO GET
YOUR TAKE ON THIS TWEET FROM
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY.
HE TWEETED THIS.
THE OLD PARTY IS DEAD.
TIME TO BURY IT, BUILD SOMETHING
NEW.
OF COURSE, WE REMEMBER IT WAS
HAWLEY WHO WAS PUMPING HIS FIST
ON JANUARY 6th.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS CALL
FOR A COURSE CORRECTION?
BECAUSE I SUPPOSE IT IS TO SOME
EXTENT THE SENATOR SAYING IT'S
TIME TO MOVE ON.
>> YEAH.
I FIND THAT INTERESTING,
ESPECIALLY COMING FROM JOSH
HAWLEY, BECAUSE THE PARTY THAT
HE ENABLE AND EMBOLDENED AND
THAT FIST PUMP IN THE AIR IS THE
PARTY THAT LOST.
SO I'M A LITTLE BIT CONFUSED AND
PERPLEXED BY THAT TWEET.
IS HE SAYING HE IS GOING TO TURN
AWAY FROM THE EXTREMISTS AND
MAGA AND ALL THESE CULTURE WARS
THAT ARE HAPPENING?
I THINK THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
I'M LOOKING -- I'M A LIFE-LONG
REPUBLICAN VOTER, BUT I AM SICK
OF THIS.
AND I AM SO GLAD THAT MODERATES
VOTED OUT THERE AND HAD THEIR
VOICES HEARD.
LOOK, I'M PAYING ATTENTION HERE.
I'M LOOKING FOR SANITY.
I'M LOOKING FOR A JOHN McCAIN
REPUBLICAN.
AND I DON'T SEE ONE RIGHT NOW
STILL.
>> AND STEPHANIE, LET'S LISTEN
TO THIS COMMENT FROM SENATOR
BILL CASSIDY OF LOUISIANA
EARLIER THIS MORN WHEN HE IS
ASKED IF TRUMP IS STILL IN
CONTROL OF THE PARTY.
A REALLY FASCINATING COMMENT.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> IF THIS IS THE RESULT OF
THESE ELECTIONS, BUT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY STILL HAS SORT
OF THE SAME LEADERSHIP AT RNC,
RONNA McDANIEL, MITCH McCONNELL,
THE SENATE REPUBLICANS, AND OF
COURSE DONALD TRUMP IS SORT OF
THE LEADER OUT THERE, IF THERE
IS NO CHANGE THERE, DO YOU THINK
THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR REPUBLICANS
GOING FORWARD?
>> FIRST, WE'RE NOT A CULT.
WE'RE NOT LIKE OKAY, THERE IS
ONE PERSON WHO LEADS OUR PARTY.
IF WE HAVE A SITTING PRESIDENT,
HE OR SHE WILL BE THE LEADER OF
OUR PARTY.
>> I MEAN, IF YOU HAVE TO SAY IT
OUT LOUD, "WE'RE NOT A CULT."
>> LIVE TV.
I APOLOGIZE ABOUT MY DOG.
ABSOLUTELY.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE THAT
CAME FROM.
THAT SEEMED VERY, VERY DEFENSIVE
TO ME.
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, AND I DON'T
MEAN TO KEEP REPEATING MYSELF.
BUT THE VOTERS HAVE SPOKEN, AND
I'M REALLY HOPEFUL FOR THAT.
LET'S SEE WHAT'S TO COME.
TUESDAY I'M HEARING THAT TRUMP
IS INVITING PEOPLE WHO HE
ENDORSED, MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO
COME DOWN AND BE THERE FOR HIS
BIG ANNOUNCEMENT.
AND LET'S SEE WHO SHOWS UP.
LET'S SEE WHO STANDS WITH HIM.
AND THEN LET'S GO FROM THERE AND
SEE WHO WILL BE IN A PRIMARY
AGAINST HIM.
BECAUSE I THINK NOW MORE THAN
EVER, I THINK THERE WILL BE MORE
PEOPLE WHO COULD PRIMARY HIM,
WHETHER THAT IS DeSANTIS.
I KNOW EVERYBODY IS TALKING
ABOUT THAT.
BUT YOU'VE GOT PENCE.
YOU'VE GOT MAYBE A KEMP, THESE
ARE JUST MY GUESSES.
SO FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
REALLY LONG TIME, I'M HOPEFUL.
AND I DON'T CARE WHAT ANYBODY
SAYS.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE BASE WILL
EVER LEAVE TRUMP UNTIL HE'S
COMPLETELY LONG GONE CONCLUSION,
FORGONE CONCLUSION.
AGAIN, SORRY ABOUT MY DOG.
BUT I THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY, HE CANNOT WIN A GENERAL,
AND PEOPLE ARE SEEING THAT NOW.
AND EVERYBODY WANTS TO VOTE FOR
THE GOOD GUY.
>> YEAH.
AND OLIVIA, LET'S SWITCH GEARS A
LITTLE BIT.
DEMOCRATS HAD A LOT GOING
AGAINST THEM, INFLATION.
THE HIGH GAS PRICES.
PEOPLE DRIVE BY THE GAS STATION
AND SEE THE HIGH GAS PRICES.
CRIME WAS ON THE MINDS OF MANY
VOTERS, DEPENDING WHERE THEY
LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
YET DEMOCRATS MANAGED TO
CONTROL, MANAGED TO KEEP CONTROL
OF THE SENATE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT WAS?
DO YOU THINK IT WAS MAYBE PARTLY
THE DOBBS DECISION, I SUPPOSE?
BUT WHAT ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
APPEAL TO AMERICANS TO HANG ON
TO THEIR DEMOCRACY, TO DEFEND
DEMOCRACY?
>> YEAH, I THINK, AGAIN, I THINK
THAT PLAYED A BIG ROLE.
LOOK, AMERICANS CAME OUT, AND
THEY VOTED FOR DEMOCRATS.
REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT TO SAY
THAT OUT LOUD, AND THEY'RE KIND
OF SITTING THERE LOOKING AT EACH
OTHER THINKING WHAT HAPPENED?
OH, ARE WE AT BAD MESSAGING?
NO, YOU RAN TERRIBLE CANDIDATES.
WE TOLD YOU WOULD LOSE AND WE
TOLD YOU THIS WOULD DESTROY THE
PARTY IF YOU WENT DOWN THAT
ROUTE, AND YOU STILL DID IT.
DEMOCRATS HAD BETTER CANDIDATES
THIS TIME AROUND.
AND I THINK THE GOP WILL
CONTINUE TO SEE LOSSES AGAIN IN
THE FUTURE IF THEY CONTINUE TO
ALLOW THESE SORT OF NARRATIVES
TO TAKE HOLD IN THE PARTY.
AND LOOK, I ALSO THINK THEY NEED
TO STOP WITH THIS ANTI-IMMIGRANT
STUFF.
I KNOW EVERYONE IS GLORIFYING
DeSANTIS' WIN IN FLORIDA.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY STANDS FOR BUSSING
PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY LIKE
CATTLE AND HAVING IMMIGRANTS
SHIPPED AROUND LIKE THAT.
IF YOU'RE GOING THE TALK ABOUT
IMMIGRATION AND BORDER SECURITY,
I NEED TO SEE SOME REAL POLICIES
HERE, AND I DON'T SEE THAT
COMING OUT OF THESE PEOPLE.
>> YEAH, STEPHANIE, I THINK THAT
WAS A BIG MESSAGE SENT BY THE
VOTERS IN THESE MIDTERMS THAT I
THINK A LOT OF VOTERS OUT THERE
ARE TIRED OF THE NASTINESS AND
THE MEANNESS AND THE CRUELTY.
PEOPLE MAKING JOKES ABOUT NANCY
PELOSI'S HUSBAND, THAT SORT OF
THING.
KARI LAKE IS ONE OF THOSE
POLITICIANS WHO DID THAT.
AND I'M CURIOUS.
I KNOW YOU CAME OUT OF ARIZONA
REPUBLICAN POLITICS.
THIS IS PRETTY FASCINATING TO
WATCH HERE, WHAT HAPPENS IF KARI
LAKE LOSES TO KATIE HOBBS.
DOES THE ARIZONA REPUBLICAN
PARTY ONLY HAVE THEMSELVES TO
BLAME IF THAT HAPPENS?
>> I THINK SO.
AND I THINK THAT CAN GO FOR A
LOT OF THE TRUMP-BACKED
CANDIDATES.
I KNOW I'M MOVING AWAY FROM KARI
LAKE FOR A MINUTE, BUT YOU THINK
ABOUT BLAKE MASTERS.
DOUG DUCEY, THE CURRENT GOVERNOR
COULD HAVE BEEN IN LINE FOR THAT
SENATE SEAT, AND HE WOULD HAVE
WON.
HE WOULD HAVE WON HANDILY, OR A
REALLY GOOD RACE AGAINST MARK
KELLY.
INSTEAD WE HAD BLAKE MASTERS.
SO I DO THINK THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, AGAIN, THEY'RE GOING HAVE
TO DO SOME SOUL-SEARCHING AND
THE STATE LEVEL AND NATIONAL
LEVEL.
WHAT HAPPENS IF KARI LOSES?
LY BE VERY, VERY HAPPY.
I BELIEVE IN MY STATE OF
ARIZONA.
I'VE SAID THAT FOR MONTHS.
NOW I'VE OPENLY ENDORSED AND
BEEN HAPPY FOR KATIE HOBBS.
I'VE BEEN TEXTING WITH HER AND
CHEERING HER ON.
SO I REALLY HOPE KATIE HOBBS
WINS, BECAUSE, AGAIN, IT WILL BE
THE VOTERS SPEAKING ABOUT NO
MORE CHAOS, NO MORE ELECTION
DENIALS, NO MORE LIES.
JUST GOVERN.
JUST DO WHAT'S BEST FOR STATE.
AND THIS IS A BORDER STATE WHERE
I'M AN IMMIGRATION HAWK.
I'M VERY CLEAR ABOUT MY VIEWS ON
IMMIGRATION HAVING LIVED IN
ARIZONA FOR 20 YEARS.
BUT SHE WILL BE WHAT IS BEST FOR
OUR STATE AND THE COUNTRY.
THE SAME WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE RACE.
MARK FINCHEM IS AN ELECTION
DENIER.
HE IS ALREADY STOKING THAT THIS
IS CHEATING.
BUT I'M REALLY PROUD OF THE
STATE OF ARIZONA THUS FA